الجميع تغريها التخفيضات خصوصا مع مجيء
الصيف والحاجه للتسوق لاجل السفر وقضاء
الاجازات وغير ذلك
الشديد فالارقام المخفضه هذه قد تكون
مغريه للتبرد بشراء مهلا فائده منها اذا
عند رؤيه اعلنت التخفيضات ما الذي ينبغي
علينا فعله هل يمكن الحفاظ على انفسنا دون
الانجراف خلف موجه الاسعار المخفضه نظريا
اليوم مشاهدينا سنتعرف على اليات مناسبه
للتعامل مع فقاعه التخفيضات والخروج منها
بمشتريات مناسبه دون اسراف لا طائل منه
ملكه شراء ما لا احتاجه وما لا ينفع تفضل
يا ملك اعرفي بالضيف معنى الان مشاهدينا
في الاستوديو صانع المحتوى الاقتصادي احمد
سند اهلا بك معنا حياك الله يا احمد اهلا
صباح الخير
[موسيقى]
اقل جوده الكومبونس بتاعتها بيكون اقل من
المنتج اللي انت عارفه الطبيعي او مزايا
بيكون فيها اقل يعني مثلا تليفزيون فتحات
في اقل الجوده بتاعه الالس دي او الالترا
اتش دي اللي احنا بنشتريها اقل الكومبوس
والبلاستيك بتاعه قل وما بينطبوش منه كميه
كبيره فالصيانه تبقى
اعتقد انا انا ما كنتش اعرفها بعرفش عادل
كان يعني
موديل دلوقتي لو لقيت عليه ريفيوز او
تقييمات قليله يبقى في الغالب الموديل ده
معمول او او منتج مشترك من المنتجات
الاصليه نعرف بهذه الطريقه طيب هذه في
التلفزيونات في الملابس في
الاشياء يعني مثلا في تخفيضات رمضان انا
واحد من الناس اشتريت اجهزه
لتجهيز السياره للبر كنت اراها بسعر بسعر
جدا منافس وجدا مغري اني انا اشتري ما
اقدر اطوف هذا السعر قاريناه بناء على
السعر اللي قبل التخفيضات هو بيحصل فعلا
ان هو بيتم رفع الاسعار قبل موجه التصفيات
اللي بتتم فانا دلوقتي الديسكونت بدل ما
كان 150 درهم بقت 90 درهم هو سعره كان
مرفوع فانا حاسس ان هو دلوقتي نزل للنص
هذا
قبلها مثلا بيوم او يومين تروح تشوف هذا
او هذه الكاس بمئه درهم ترجع تشوفها
بالتخفيضات ب80 بالضبط لانه هو كان رافع
السعر قبل
وانا مش عارف ده حقيقي ممكن تشتريه بس هو
دلوقتي قلل
هامش الربح الربح يعني كان بيكسب فيه مثلا
100% دلوقتي بيكتب 80% فانت حاسس ان انت
وفرت وبناء عليها هتشتري ايتم ثاني وثالث
وهكذا وكثير قوي دلوقتي بنتعامل مع
المواقع التسويق او الشارع اونلاين ان هي
مجله مش مرتاحه واحنا عايزين نشتري حاجه
عايزين نتفرج طب فيما يت
علق خاص بفتره التخفيضات او بيخلوا مثلا
اللي عليها تخفيضات تكون ملابس الموسم
اللي اللي قبل او مثلا مقاسات مكسوره ما
في كل
دلوقتي بقت منتشره صعب جدا ان انا افرق ما
بيننا وما بين البراند الاصليه النسخ
الجوده ان هو يبان ان هو فعلا المنتج ده
الكلام خطير بانه اذا اذا ماركه معينه
تقدم تخفيضات على هذه الماركه ويكون كوبي
او تشتري مثلا مكان موجود في اي دوله ايا
كانت تشتريه هاي كوبي وهو ممكن ما يكونش
براند الاصلي عشان كده ممكن تلاقي مثلا
الباركود او الكود اللي انت تقدرش منه على
الويب سايت يتاكد اذا كان المنتج ده فعلا
مش عايز اقول اسماء براندات يعني بس موجود
عندهم ولا لا
ربما عشان كده طبعا لو انت لقيت ان الساهر
نازل كتير تقدر تحكم اذا كان المنتج ده
اصلي ولا لا واهم حاجه نبقى عاملين
ميزانيه للحاجه اللي احنا عايزينها
ومواصفات يعني مثلا عايز تشتري تيشرت ما
تدخلش على فئه الملابس والدور لان في
الغالب هتشتري حاجات ما كنتش متخيله انت
اكتب هتلاقي عندك وايت تطلع وتنقي واحد
وتبقى حافظ الميزانيه الحاجه اللي انت
عايزها بمواصفات تحديدا لا ده الموضوع
مليان
ما هو الفكره ان هو لو دخلت بعدها يعني
انت اشتريت دلوقتي المنتج دول اخر 3 بي سي
هتلاقي اخر ثلاث قطع موجودين زي ما هم
شكرا جزيلا احمد سند على المحتوى
شكرا ههه شكرا
مروه البرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات